porsche is reviving a classic but with
modern technology the new targus design
is patterned on its predecessors with
the roll bar instead of a center pillar
and with a wraparound rear window
the ingeniously designed roof mechanism
is state of the art the target comes
with all-wheel drive and a top speed of
294 kilometers an hour
the 400 horsepower on board propelled it
from zero to 100 kilometers per hour and
4.6 seconds
i'm taga
but more important on the design side is
understand the target is based on the
regular 911 convertible what's new is
that the target's roof opens and closes
like the convertibles again
is
the new all-wheel target has the
instantly recognizable look of the 911
the targus rear wheel wells are each 22
millimeters lighter than those of the
two-wheel drive 911 carrera models and
the tires they house are 10 millimeters
wider
then yes
it was built in 1965
was responding to consumer fears
a famous open road endurance race in
sicily and it's on country roads of this
porsche design masterpiece shows its
best sign with a mixture of powerful
acceleration and extreme stability and
curves
the porsche project manager says the
suspension is tuned differently from
that of the carrera 4 convertible both
suspension types offered with the targa
have rebound buffer springs on both the
front and rear axles
they offer more comfort without a
decline in driving dynamics
a 7-speed manual transmission is
standard in the target and that's a
world premiere in the passenger car
segment a 7-speed dual clutch
transmission is optional
the targa's interior is classic 911 with
its typical arrangement of instruments
the sound of the engine is music to a
car lover's ears
is
911
german dealerships this summer
price tag starting at 127 thousand six
hundred euros
so
the gulf is volkswagen's best-selling
model now it comes in an all-electric
version which means goals can be had
with every kind of engine
other manufacturers develop the e-cars
as separate models and produce them in
separate factories volkswagen's usual
looks like conventional golfs and is
produced in wolfsburg germany in the
same factory as they are
nothing einstein
says that when you get in you don't
notice much difference from a regular
but when you pull into the service
station at the latest it's clear this
isn't a conventional gold
the eagle can fully recharge by being
plugged into any standard power outlet
for 13 hours
at commercial charging pillars an 80
percent charge takes just 30 minutes
but there are still too few public
charging stations
kilometers an hour in just four seconds
plenty of speed for city driving
produces maximum torque from the first
time it turns over through to the
highest revs
the e-gulf is supposed to travel 190
kilometers on a full charge if you drive
with an eye to conserving energy if you
don't the battery can be empty in half
that distance the driver controls the
relationship between power and energy
consumption with his driving style and
the poor energy regeneration levels
closes the eagle drives very well
the co2 emissions level can't be beat
the car emits zero co2
we asked passersby in berlin what they
thought about the exhibited eagle yeah
this woman thinks the eagles is great
for the environment but a 100 kilometer
range is too short
but some people think it's a great idea
this man is enthusiastic he calls the
car fantastic
is
and if you're still wondering what an
electric cars motor sounds like listen
closely
the ego whispers sometimes the quiet
drive can be disquieting but all in all
the battery-powered engine has proved
itself in everyday traffic
on the outside the e-golf is just like
any other except that the logos on the
radiator grille and at the rear have one
letter identifying the car as electric
like other electric cars the e-golf does
without an exhaust pipe
the interior is very much like other
goals because as the saying goes never
change a winning team
a in germany the eagle has a starting
price of just under 35 000 euros
the new bmw i8 will be hitting the
street soon in june the two plus two
coupe is a plug-in hybrid and comes with
the power of a 1.5 liter internal
combustion engine as well as an electric
engine
the combined system packs a
kilowatt punch in germany the i8 will
cost 126 000 euros
with summer approaching renault has
revamped the convertible version of its
megane
buyers have a choice of four different
engines including the new energy tce 130
which consumes 6.4 liters of fuel for
100 kilometers a panoramic glass roof
allows those inside to enjoy the sun
even on chilly days the basic model
costs 28 100 euros in germany
the ford transit has been one of
europe's most popular utility vehicle
since its launch in 1965
now the eighth generation is hitting the
roads the most obvious change is in the
dimensions a major markup from the
outgoing version
and between front rear and all-wheel
drive depending on the payload
the version with the long wheelbase and
high roof is ideal for bulky loads while
the flatbed version is more suited for
building materials the van edition could
seat up to 18 people
is the variability
he can adjust his seat to ensure
their journey
all versions have the same width
2.47 meters the length varies between 5
meters 20 and 7 meters 58
the sliding door is now wider making it
possible to load a standard european
pallet sideways
there are plenty of flashing rings to
tie down your cargo
that delivery drivers face on an
everyday basis
all models come with 2.2 liter diesel
engines delivering between 74 and 114
kilowatts
some fatherless
absorb
system
it comes with special grade steels and
an array of airbags
on the active safety front there's a
lane keeping alert and a special esp
that gently slows the vehicle if your
speed around bends is excessive
ford expects the versatility of a new
transit to make it very competitive on
the international market
so what's our viewers overall
impressions
on a regular basis
my
you